it's too early you know we don't know  what Hillary's stances are all the  issues but this is what i can tell you  and maybe let me conclude on this i  voted against the war in iraq and not  only that i vote against that i helped  lead the effort and many of the things  that I said back then turned out to be  true I mean the massive destabilization  in the region I am helping right now to  vdf it against the trans-pacific  partnership because I believe it  continues a trend of horrendous trade  policies which have cost us millions of  decent paying jobs I helped lead the  effort against the Keystone pipeline  because I don't think we should be  transporting some of the dirtiest fuel  in the world and we got to be really  vigorous in terms of transforming our  energy system so those are some of my  views and we'll see where Secretary  Clinton comes out